NOWITZKI.
>> HE'S SPECIAL.
>> YOU LOOK AT THE WEST AND YOU
SEE A PLETHORA OF INJURIES
AROUND, YOU KNOW, THE LAKERS
AREN'T FULL STRENGTH.
YOUR TEAM ISN'T FULL STRENGTH.
YOU KNOW, PORTLAND, CJ McCULLUM
IS COMING BACK.
I COULD GO DOWN THE LINE.
EVERYONE HEALTHY ON YOUR TEAM.
WHAT WOULD PROPEL YOU TO BE THAT
TEAM THAT SAID WE ARE NOW
CONTENDERS AND NOT JUST A
PLAYOFF TEAM?
>> I MEAN, I THINK OBVIOUSLY
IT'S A CRAZY RHYTHM.
WE PLAY ALMOST EVERY OTHER GAME,
A LOT OF BACK TO BACKS.
WE JUST TRY TO GO GAME BY GAME
SO WE CAN BE IN THE PLAYOFF AND
THEN GO FROM THERE GAME BY GAME.
>> LAST THING FROM ME, LUKA IS
THIS, YOU AND DWIGHT HOWARD TIED
WITH THE MOST TECHNICAL FOULS
WITH 15.
IF YOU GET ONE MORE, YOU GET
SUSPENDED A GAME.
ON YOUR LAST SIX, HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO REMAIN LUKA AND PLAY TO
A HIGH LEVEL BUT ALSO NOT LET
YOUR EMOTIONS GET OUT OF
CONTROL?
>> FOR SURE.
THE FREE SHOT WASN'T MYSELF THIS
SEASON.
YOU KNOW, I'M COMPLAINING WAY
TOO MUCH.
I GOT TO WORK ON THAT.
I JUST GOT TO STAY CALM AND JUST
NOT TALK TO THEM.
I GOT TO LEARN FROM THAT.
>> NOTHING TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
TONIGH